so this is not the type of story I would
normally talk about but it is kind of a
perfect mix of pop culture and current
events with the ongoing gun violence
issues that we have in the United States
so I do want to take a few minutes to
talk about it a group of people showed
up at a Popeye's fast-food restaurant
and demanded fried chicken sandwiches at
gunpoint this was in Houston Texas and
to understand this you need to
understand what's been going on with
Popeyes and chicken sandwiches the whole
backstory is that Popeyes introduced the
chicken sandwich offering and they did
it with a very well calculated viral
marketing campaign and it became a
complete social media sensation and
while I haven't been to a fast-food
restaurant in more than 15 years at this
point I was still following it as
something interesting from a social and
business and marketing perspective and
these sandwiches went crazy these
sandwiches at Popeyes sold out
nationwide and they've been sold out for
some time now it was a three dollar
99-cent chicken sandwich I believe
people went crazy for this sandwich and
they ran out of ingredients and now
they've said we don't know when it'll be
back and we're trying to source what we
need for it and the genius of the
campaign in part was that Popeyes social
media campaign sort of went after
chick-fil-a a rival chicken chain
tongue-in-cheek but very very effective
Wendy's jumped in on it as well I don't
care about this food I never go to these
places but it was clever and it worked
all over the countries the sandwiches
are just totally sold out so in Houston
Texas not shockingly shortly before 9
p.m. three men and two women show up
with at least one firearm they had
already gone through the drive-thru they
had already been told the store was out
of chicken sandwiches and they tried to
go inside with their firearm to demand
chicken sandwiches one report says that
an employee locked the door before
anybody got in another report says the
people did get in so I'm unclear as to
which version of that detail is accurate
the group reportedly had a baby with
them but the baby was left in the car
when they tried to use a weapon to force
the store to give them chicken
sandwiches police as of this morning
are looking for the suspects maybe by
the time you hear this or watch this the
suspects will have been caught now I
know I say this all the time we have
a problem in the United States with
people who see guns as a tool to solve
problems I get that this is chicken
sandwiches but it's the same damn
pattern I've been pointing out for years
in the United States yes we have too
many guns yes it's too easy to get guns
we lack basic gun safety regulations
ammunition should be more expensive all
of that stuff is true it all needs to be
dealt with but we also have a cultural
problem with guns and one piece of that
problem is that people think of firearms
as ways to solve problems or to get
things personal problems in the United
States too many people see as possibly
being solved with a gun political
problems people see is possibly being
solved with a gun cartoonishly here a
popular sold out chicken sandwich
availability problem is seen as
potentially being solvable with a gun
now of course the poor decision-making
skills by these individuals are
particularly to blame in this particular
case but there are people who want to
ignore the broader context that as silly
as trying to get sold out chicken
sandwiches with a gun is it's happening
in a country where people try to solve
all sorts of problems with guns and to
pretend that that is not the context is
deceptive it's incomplete and it is not
going to further an understanding of or
a solution to what it is that we are
currently dealing with here in any case
I hope that they find these people as of
right now they are still looking and no
even this is not going to get me back to
fast food I think I'm actually trying to
think I've said 15 years but I'm really
kind of getting up there now I think
it's been more like 18 years yeah you
know there's one exception when a KFC
opened in a place I was living when I
was in my early 20s I think I did once
or twice go over to KFC as I recently
said on the bonus show and I got one of
those crispy strip meals with the mashed
potatoes and that great coleslaw that
KFC has I'm sure it's terrible for you
but it tastes great but other than those
two slip-ups at KFC it's been like 17 or
18 years
since I've really been to a fast-food
restaurant anyway I don't know you've
tried the sandwich let me know if it's
actually that that good